okay I want to thank the organizers for
making this this week happen and in for
inviting me to speak um I'm going to
talk about some work I did with Fernando
a while ago and also a little bit of
follow-up work since then um and this
will relate you will see actually
relation to the previous talk in fact
you could even consider it a sort of
proof of some of the things that that
the palo mentioned ok so this I'm going
to talk about uh about non signaling
sorry about this non signaling
correlations and so by correlations I
think by now you're all pretty familiar
with the idea you have Alice and Bob
they each get some input a and B they
output X and Y and we're interested in
the joint conditional probability
distributions p of x y given a B and
just to reiterate things you've been
hearing before we divide this into
several types there's local in which
they just act independently local hidden
variable in which they act independently
but they have some shared randomness
quantum where they act they have some
entangled state and they choose some
measurement and then of course non
signaling so I think you've you've seen
all of these quite a few times over
previous days but please ask me again
for questions if you you know at any
point if you want to remind her um I
want to talk a little bit about why
these are worthy of study because I used
to be a box hater I would you know I've
seen that the q IP and we come on
quantum information processing not you
know unphysical generalizations of
quantum mechanics information processing
uh but the reason why I've come around
two boxes um so first of all you know we
do have to actually deliver the scope of
quantum mechanics and and part of that
is you know if you're going to draw a
line you have to have quantum mechanics
on one side of something on the other
side so that's the sort of the
foundational approach of quantum
mechanics it's a separating quantum from
local hidden variable but also not
signaling on the other side is sort of a
foundational interest this work is going
to be about the operational side of it
so one way to think about non signaling
boxes is quan mechanics is a way of you
take a stick
measurement and you get output
statistics but there's a large class of
measurement that we're interested in
which our local measurements and in that
case the the joint statistics look like
these joint conditional probability
distributions you know if you never make
an entangled measurement a quantum state
can be described in terms of these
things and for this work it turns out to
be very productive to view quantum
states through that lens and then of
course there's a computational side in
terms of MIP star and things like that
which which I think you've heard about
on previous days and and I won't get
into more but that's obviously a very
interesting side as well so I basically
thinking about quantum states not in
terms of vectors in a Hilbert space but
in terms of their these conditional
probability distributions you know had
some has some usefulness to it and you
know why focus on this this non
signaling regime um okay this is their
foundational reasons that it's sort of a
foundation you know in terms of what is
a plausible physical theory it's sort of
well motivated in that way operationally
is nice as well so it's nice about it
just just operationally is that these
are the class of theories that have a
partial trace so quantum mechanics is
nice in part because it has a partial
trace if you have general non if you
have general bipartite correlations if
they're signaling then they don't have a
partial trace because Alice's output
might depend on what Bob does and so you
just can't talk about Alice's system by
itself and so if it's non signaling or
the definition of non signaling is that
there's a well-defined partial trace
that Alice's output depends if you just
look at how Alice's output and input are
related you can talk about that without
talking about Bob's input you will have
to bring in Bob's output but it's not
going to depend on Bob's input and so
there's a meaningful partial trace and
in terms of just working with these
mathematically and in terms of things
i'll prove later on this is crucial
another nice thing about not signaling
distributions is that there are i mean
all these things are convex sets but
this one is described by a nice short
list of linear inequalities and so you
have an efficient linear programming
characters
of Nan signaling distributions so
quantum is well get into complexity
later the other two classes the local
hidden variable in quantum are much
harder and of course sometimes hardness
is interesting a good thing but
sometimes you want to be easy and not
solutions are easy to optimize over okay
so those are our distributions I'm sorry
those are those are our net our
distribution so what are what are the
possible our joint non-local just
probability distributions conditional
probability submissions the dual side is
to look at games and again you've heard
a lot about this so I don't want to
spend much time on it you know in
general for a game you have inputs
chosen according some Joint Distribution
mu CH and general be correlated there's
some payoff function and then the value
of a game is just sort of your
respective payoff once you have games
you can talk about what is what is the
value sorry this is a value of game
using strategy p but you can say what is
the value of the game for the best
possible strategy either if the strategy
is within local hidden variable or
quantum or not signaling um and the
complexity as you've as you've heard
before classical capacities NP hard even
to do a constant approximation that's
that's the PCP theorem the quantum
complexity is is really unknown we don't
have any I guess we know it's computable
but but not much more than that um and
and then on signaling value as I
mentioned before it has a linear
programming characterization ok so
that's the landscape that that we're
going to talk about really a little fast
but but please stop me with questions at
any time wait for the quantum value
don't we know and fee hardness the issue
is just that we don't have an upper oh
sorry you're right yes true we don't
know an upper bound we just we know it
we we do know lower bounce right back
yes not completely i know right but i
mean as of you know a year or two ago um
there's uh yeah I guess for two players
it might we don't have the NP hardness
for constant approximation where's what
is Toma yes so in two players even less
is known I'm not gonna shed much light
on that and save talk uh so well I'll
send a little bit of light on it but I
ok so when I was half a day is monogamy
so meaning that a correlation cannot be
shared with an unlimited number of other
parties so monogamy in particular means
not extendable so what is extendable at
a correlation a joint probability
distribution is extendable if I can if
it if there exists another non signaling
correlation with K box such that if you
take Alice in any one of the bombs and
look at their marginal then you have the
same not the same joint conditional
probabilities mission so it's crucial
here these things are non signaling
right if it were not single ease
wouldn't even be defined because I've
used the idea of a partial trace so just
you know why not signaling I couldn't
even get to this box with without
without that ok so uh so okay fine
that's the definition of K extendable
when it is possible well for locally
invariable correlations everything is
always infinitely extendable because
Alice and Bob just have some shared
randomness but this randomness could
have been shared with any number of
people it's a classical string you know
it could be three published in the
newspaper and then there could be
everyone who knows the random string
could be another Bob so there's every
local invertible correlation is is
infinitely extendable and in fact the
converse is also true that anything
that's in fully extendable must be a
local hidden variable correlation at
least if the you know that might not be
true if the alphabet size is like
uncountable but for finite output a size
that that's certainly true and one
reason you can immediately see that is
if you're instantly
standable then you could have an
infinity of Bob and so the joint
input-output behavior of all those Bob's
becomes essentially like a like a
classical variable and so if you
condition on you know if you look at
enough of the Bob you can completely
work out the the local the Bob input
output relation and then conditioning on
that you have a you have a local hidden
variable distribution that's the hand
waving version I'll give you more a more
quantitative version of that later on so
this monogamy ideas already have many
many I think it's it used implicitly
people don't call it monogamy it's used
quite a bit the idea of quantum key
distribution or or or a quantum
misgiving secrecy is due to the idea of
monogamy that if the if the
eavesdroppers correlate with a message
then that will disrupt the type of
correlation that the legitimate parties
have and especially the types of device
independent quantum key distribution
where you certify it using bellows tests
that says that if the two parties win a
for example of CH SH game at high enough
rate then that is evidence that's proof
that they are not that those the output
of that CH SH game was not correlated
with some other with some East robber so
that's you know the monogamy principle
is guaranteeing that an eavesdropper is
not correlated with their with a match
um it also can be used to give a
hierarchy of approximation for local
hidden variable correlations if I want
to just search you know if I if I'm
given I join up a joint conditional
probability distribution and I want to
know is this a local hidden variable
distribution or not that's an np-hard
problem but I've but I can ask is it k
extendable and I can solve that in time
that's exponential in K because this is
just asking if it's k extendable is just
a giant linear program and the size of
the linear program is the the Bob spaces
get blown up to the power K and uh and I
just have that many variables and
roughly that many constraints and I can
just search over this thing in
polynomial time this gives an algorithm
for approximating local hidden variable
relations of course this is the time we
don't know how good it is right we don't
know how close it comes to local in
variable as a function of K and that's
one of the things that I'll that I'll
talk about and finally also it gives d
phonetic theorems it says that if a
state is if K extendable then it should
be approximately separable so here I've
jumped from talking about distributions
to quantum states but a quantum state
can be completely determined by local
measurements and so if the thing
responds to local measurements in a way
that looks just like a local hidden
variable theory then you can show that
it must be close to separable as well
and i'll talk later about how to how to
make that a little quantitative yeah
um no where's there's no where's the
symmetry requirement that's um well yes
it won't be I mean some people would say
that the margin that the Bob have to be
symmetric I had not imposed that but
what would be would be weaker than this
so this is this is not this sort of the
opposite of monogamous this is saying
shareable this saying you know shareable
up to k parties and I guess what what
Cheryl means is that those correlations
could be reproduced at the marginals of
another one above another distribution
so I don't know how to weaken it further
that but it'd be interesting if there
was a way yes that's true but then it
wouldn't be that it with you and see the
property P I wanna know is P k
extendable and after the mutual
information is sort of a more you know
saying is narrowing down not just a pee
but or maybe a larger class of things
now I get me one slight weakening and
something is true for epr pairs you
could say if Alice and Bob share p then
Allison Charlie should be decoupled so
that's the type of maybe that's a way
that you could you could we can miss or
yeah but um so yeah actually this it's
be interesting to try to say that
systematically you know to sort of
generalize that into a larger
definitional and I'm not sure if I other
to it I'll mention one straightening
that people do sometimes is to impose at
the bars of symmetric and that's
basically equivalent cuz if you have a
que extension you could symmetrized
about and you still have one so having a
pea extension or a symmetric a extension
of the same thing yeah so that's crystal
related free know which is the
intersection of this case stand alone
under quantum world
Sokka Divya for a fixed k intersection
is just a local hidden body or something
so I think that I in Pablo's work they
showed that I think I'm sure there's
there's never converted with community
with utmost Kiba oh right oh sorry yeah
if you uh right so sometimes if K
becomes larger than the number of
answers for Bob's and it exactly
conversions is that what you mean um
yeah III don't know about like k equals
to type things I'm not I'm not sure
about that I do know that it uh yeah um
well let me let me talk about what we do
know about conversion so result number
one about you know how Nicole question
about this this is a hierarchy gives you
an algorithm tell you about quantum
state so now the whole question is how
can we make this quantity right so this
is a way of approximating local in
variables so our first result is if you
have a que extendable distribution then
you wanna I want to claim that there
exists a mobile big memorable theory
that is close to it uh unfortunately
these are conditional probability
distribution so if I just have to
probability distributions I can measure
distance by the trace distance but for a
conditional distribution I have to also
talk about the inputs as well as we help
us and so the inputs the best we can
achieve is this slightly funny thing
where for any distribution for Alice
there exists a local hidden variable
theory that gives a good approximation
relative to that distribution okay so
this is weaker than saying there's just
a local hidden variable theory that
looks closed for any pair of imports
this says if you know a fix of
distribution for Alice
there'll be a local hidden variable
theory that will fool that distribution
of Alice and any input of box okay and
how well is it bullet pretty well it's
square root of the log of the number of
input for Alice / k and so basically you
get nothing until k is more than the log
of the number of inputs and then after
that you get a decent approximation and
this is we're often interested in this
thing just being some low constant and
so the question is how large it to take
K before that happens and remember that
K appeared in the exponent so we really
really don't want it to be large and
this is nice because K only has to be as
much as the log of the number again so
the computational cost will be not too
terrible not be will not grow
exponentially with any any part of me
yeah um yes all them let me just come
back to that in like 15 minutes because
yeah that's one of the open question um
so um what was previously known in the
world of Naga knee so one of the kind of
landmark results displayed in the paper
that coin monogamy I'm not sure I said
that if K is larger than the number of
outputs of Bob then p is exactly a local
hidden variable theory and basically I'm
sorry the number of inputs above number
of inputs about and basically that's
because you can just imagine a que
extension if you have this this K
extension that each Bob can be getting a
different input and then that could you
know that would basically completely
characterize bottle looks like it uh
yeah it would um you know once you once
you condition out all of those you
basically know about you completely no
Bob's behavior so but here look how big
Cassidy if you do something exponential
or not you have a trivial algorithm so
this was an interesting thing in terms
of the abstract theory of monogamy but
if you want an algorithm this is the
kind of result that you need and so this
it belongs to a class of recent results
I think started by the bronica seminar
paper where these monogamy and
can any type results turn from being
kind of just statements about states and
visits that were kind of nice in
themselves but never lets you a youthful
algum two things that have actual of
giving us none other than new algorithms
yeah so that's not only the same note or
something that is one the kind of things
again mentioned racers it knows you see
yes so the way to interpret one so are
on tourism yeah the thing is we don't
sure but one lf-cc is it's like the one
norm of the of the output statistics
right so you won LSU he means you
disallow a joint measurement you have to
measure Bob and send a message to Alice
on the measure Alice and then the if you
look at this is a classical this is the
distance of classical distributions
right so you have to you're talking
about the one normal use of these
classical distributions and that's like
saying the one LS a scene or ms is
pretty much the same thing that it's
it's looking at the the difference of
the classical distributions that you get
from measuring yeah so this view
endearing one yeah so we should think of
it is a marginal of the jury input joint
situations yeah even though yeah you
that's even a little it's a little
better than that because it works for
any joint distribution yes that's right
yeah yeah
s'okay extendable States you can search
over or you can optimize over there's a
linear program for them that's
exponential and K and so as soon as you
have so let's go back to to hear so you
know local hidden variable theories are
hard to search over to test membership
in and so this gives us a way to
approximate local hidden variable models
which are these empty heart center um
okay uh this is for to party games our
results also i worked nicely for for
multi-party games so intuitively if i
want to handle so if i want to handle
end players then i'm paying here the log
of the input size so if I've end players
their input size is that to the nth
power but I'm taking a log in it then
you know I should just multiply by n
that's sort of intuitively how it should
get worse at their end players that's a
little bit too good to be true because
the end players are really separate
players and you're not stream them as a
block but that they give you the idea
that it shouldn't scale too horribly
when you have more players and in fact
if you want to control going to control
end players then you just can't a factor
and on the right hand side and so what
exactly is a theorem now we we will
demand that p be symmetric actually in
the other enough paper that Fernando
talked about we have sort of in an
asymmetric definity theorem but that's
sort of it's a good deal more obligated
to say let's take a symmetric joint
conditional probability distribution and
suppose that we're asking product
questions then if you look at some
subset of end of the players then they
should be playing approximately a local
hidden variable theory in fact not only
that approximately an iid strategy for a
mixture of iid strategies so this is
more like classic definitive that if I
Mike a systems I trace down to N and
then I should get something that looks
like a mixture of tensor powers and this
is like the tensor power in the inbox
world you know you have just a
independent independent strategy
conditioned on some cognitive areas and
I'm mostly going to talk about theorem
one because this one just introduces a
lot more baggage but once you have the
information theory ideas for theorem one
then that shows you how to how you can
get the other one and a previous version
for of this form was found by gustan de
land toner and again they get the N
squared over K dependence but you see
here one of the inputs without the log
which is which is deadly because again
this shows up in the exponent you know k
have to be bigger than than this and so
it's a nice theorem in terms of
understanding correlations but does not
give any non-trivial help them okay so
um that those are kind of the main
results then I'm going to talk about um
let me give you a sketch of the proof of
it um to the the proof idea and so
remember the family that if you have an
extension then the marginal should look
approximately like local hidden variable
um so the idea is you know your classic
your classic rounding method we're sort
of either one thing is true or another
thing is true and it either way sort of
it takes you it makes it better so one
possibility is to look at @ p @ alice
and the first bump so one possibility is
that they're already on cortland ok
Zoe's a possibility and if so great
you're done because the extension if you
look at Alice with any one of the Bob's
this is equivalent to your original non
signaling distribution so if you can
prove that Allison any one of the bobs
have the right distribution then you're
done and so in this case you're very
happy you're done but if not what does
that mean that means it Alice and Bob
want to correlate it and what it needs
to be correlated means that if you know
about one very
then you learn about the other one and
so that means if I condition on Bob ones
input and output then that should sort
of reduce the entropy of Alice and so
that means that there's a sort of less
room for mutual information between
Alice and Bob too and if I keep doing
this then eventually I should run out of
mutual information and how many times
have to do it well and about Cobb rolls
beyond mutual information which is where
the where the logs come in because we're
fighting n trapeze here instead of
fighting other things like two norms and
scale with judge so that was a little
bit non-technical let me make it
slightly more true and and technical um
so this is a statement I'll give a
version that did not involve any um any
conditioning and I was not here for
night of shops maybe he showed a very
similar kind of statement but it's very
it's worth knowing so you have Alice's
output and then all of them the K Bob
outlets and if you look at the mutual
information it's trivially upper bounded
by the log of the size of Alex's outlet
but also with the chain rule we can
write into the Sun like this and so what
that means you have K terms here that
add up to this thing at least one of
these terms is going to be small right
it's going to be at most this quantity
right here which was what appeared in
our hair about and so what does it mean
that this this quantity fall this is a
conditional mutual information if you
average over all the way to setting this
variable on how correlated are these two
variables and so this says that for the
average setting here these two are
nearly decoupled they're nearly product
and so these are classical variables so
let's just call these y 1 through by j
minus 1 our hidden variable our local
hidden variable sorry the one that sort
of the shared classical ran this and
then once you condition on it it leaves
the outputs nearly d college and so your
thing is nearly a local unit variable T
so that's the rough idea of the proof
it's more choosing previous line but
still missing the inputs right this is a
very static thing but these are
conditional probabilities mission what
do we do about the inputs um that is
yeah all that meet each other techs are
doesn't that hidden variable theory only
work for x and y j what about for the
other was right so that's the beautiful
thing about teh extension if you prove
it for any j i said all the marginals
are the same so you know good yeah so
it's weird you know you couldn't prove
it for x and y 1 but it turned that it
was true for them too all right and I
guess the reason in X or Y 1 maybe they
were correlated but if you had just
known what to condition on they wouldn't
do what if you want to kill that hood
okay so um uh oh sorry then the last
thing is you know this is mutual
information but we wanted something
about trace norm that's just something
called pin screws inequality and then
you get a square root and basically use
you know there's no dimension doctors
what do you make them okay so what are
the inputs on this equation is a little
bit of a beast but it's basically the
same as before except now we have to
maximize over all the inputs right so
these mutual information is still upper
bounded by the same thing even you max
by the overall inputs and then if you
look if you do this conditional mutual
information business you'll notice that
this last term is the only one to depend
on V sub K so we can kind of pull that
turn out and just kind of stare at that
one separately and we just look at this
term you can show that this just apply
pin store directly to here and it's you
know comparable to this this distance
right here um and once you've done that
you sort of peeled that off and you can
you know we won't bother you anymore and
then you can you can approach befuck k
minus 1 B sub K minus 2 and so on and
one by one you kind of apply the
inequalities you applied before and and
more or less more or less the same
argument the same argument works so
uh yeah I don't want to like spend too
much time in that basically you do have
to worry about the inputs there's some
technicalities which are in our paper we
kind of go over this carefully but it
doesn't substantially changed big idea
yeah wait let me write so what you get
if you get a sum of K of these terms and
you okay they just know the one of them
smaller okay you'll also notice uh you
know we had to maximize over Bob's
inputs and it was crucial that B sub K
just appeared by itself in the last term
so we could kind of analyze that one by
yourself and this is why you can't
maximize over Allison input at the same
time because alex is if input appears
every single one now you could take pay
attentions of Alice to we just and I
would love it if somebody could make
that work we were unable to um okay so
at this point I you know maybe it's
getting a little bit technical I want to
mention that these same techniques apply
to an easier problem this is some new
work and I think it's simple enough the
whole proof you can just really see on
one very short slide so forget about
boxes forget about Allison Bob being
friends they're not anymore they're
playing a non-cooperative game so a game
in which they're each trying to maximize
their own utility so Alice will choose
the strategy PA Bible to the strategy PB
there's some value that that they each
receive which is given by these these
inner products a Nash equilibrium is a
set of probabilities where neither one
can unilaterally improve their pale and
an epsilon approximate Nash is one where
maybe they can prove the payoff but not
by very much not by more than epsilon by
deviating from it expansion and assume
that any VA and VB are vectors of all
entry founded between minus one and one
just reset the scale for the problem so
that's neither Nash equilibrium they're
hard to compute as I mentioned in it a
natural relaxation is a correlated
equilibrium so in this case they follow
a correlator strategy you can think of
it as the external signal that gives
a hint of how they should play but of
course they're still free to deviate
from they could ignore the hint and play
their own weight and so it's an
equilibrium if they cannot improve their
balance so the sort of a classic example
is became chicken where you can either
drive or stop at it and you know if you
have I Drive and my opponent stops good
for me I get to my where I go shop
faster by stop and my opponent drives
you know I'm delayed a little bit but
it's really terrible if we both drive
and an example of correlated equilibrium
is a traffic light which gives one
single one player green light get the
player a red light and if you see the
red light you know the other players
driving so you have no incentive to
deviate from that similarly if you see
the green light you know the other
players stopped so you have no incentive
to deviate from from driving and so even
though what I love about that is that
even if there are no police officers the
traffic lights are self-enforcing
because just knowing that everyone else
is playing according to that equilibrium
is reason enough for me to follow the
traffic light um so the other support
later equilibria can be good for society
and they also can be found official
using linear program because these are
just linear constraints on the
probabilities and essentially one or
anything about Nash equilibria is that
it follows all the linear constraints of
a correlated equilibrium plus it has
this extra non linear constraint of
being a product distribution so that's
why Nash equilibria are hard to find and
correlated equilibria are easy to so
what I mean by complexity to find the
exact Nash equilibria it's something
called PPA d complete which is a really
there's a lot of nice complexity theory
there which i will not get into
basically the problem of that nationally
but always exist you can't ask whether
the existence hamster really yes let
subsided it's hard and to optimize over
that's just NP complete so that's a
simpler thing to to think about epsilon
approximate Nash you can do much better
it's sort of quasi polynomial if N and M
are equal is nville law again so just a
little more than polynomial and it's at
least as hard as plan to click so that
means we
eat this one time is tight so that we
know for a pocket click the new result
which I don't want to you know Trump it
too much that I think it's kind of cute
is another algorithm for a plan
approximate Nash with exactly the same
run time up to constant from the
exponent so it's uh you know
algorithmically is not that new but
what's cool about it is that the
approach is totally different and I
think this sheds light on how to
understand some of these these
hierarchies the old algorithm is very
simple it's based on the numerator over
next for the set of probabilities the
set of probabilities you can cover with
a small net of points such as any
probability it's close to it in a
certain sense I really recommend talking
to Marius for for more detail about it
he helped me understand a lot more
recently this algorithm uses a totally
dinner but uses k extendable
distributions so what is the algorithm
we will search is very simple yes as you
might imagine instead of having one Bob
of K box and we'll search over
distributions for one Alice and all of
the box just probability distributions
and what are the constraints we want it
so that if you look at Alice and any one
of the Bob's and you condition on the
behavior of all previous Bob's that
should be a correlated equilibrium ok so
that's it those are the constraints it
Sally these are linear constraints um so
this is a big linear program so runs in
time polynomial in the dimension which
in this case means basically polynomial
and n to the K why does it work well the
claim is that most of these conditional
so all the conditional distributions are
correlated equilibria that's the
constraint from the LP and the claim is
that most of them are nearly product and
why is that true because of conditional
mutual information so the average
conditional mutual information averaging
from I've rooms from one decay of Alice
with one of the Bob's conditioned on all
the previous Bob's is at most log M the
number of strategies for Alice / k the
number of extensions so if you take k to
be log M over epsilon square
this conditional mutual information on
average is epsilon squared or less and
so then when you do pinsker you get that
your your variational distance the
product is that most epsilon so it's uh
the other algorithm was also very simple
but I like how this is a pretty clean
and simple proof that you can get a quad
v polynomial time outfit okay so this is
a yes oh this is unrelated to the non
signaling games but i think it's the
simplest example of the use of these
hierarchies to solve a non-trivial
problem you could also use it to
optimize you don't have to do it for
nash you could optimize over you want to
apply the quadratic function over the
set of probability distributions the
same idea would work you have the same
hardness and the same the same runtime
any questions about this before i go
back to cooperative games exchange under
babies oh yeah so yeah we should talk
about that more often or so maybe so
definitely if you had some a different
constraints the runtime is still
polynomial in this and it's strictly a
better approximation uh and I have no
idea how to improve the analysis also
you if you can improve the analysis in
general you could sell planted click a
time better than n to the log n so what
well into the yeah um which would be you
know to be great but it's so um but I
think a very nice general question is
with these information three techniques
we're really now starting to understand
KX can go pretty well when you throw in
ppt constraints we know there's some
cases where you can do much better and
we're really just in the dark about how
well you do in general I think I said
really I think that's a prob i would
really really likes a little more about
uh but i don't have many many of these
okay so going back to the two games what
we get here um so one application to
this is if you have um if you have a
free game
meaning that the input the questions are
uncorrelated then I you can get it you
get a good approximation so you can
approximate the value of a pregame
efficiently so if you have a pregame you
can optimize over not signaling
strategies and you get a runtime which
looks like like this thing so it's
basically some small factors and then in
the exponent log of the number of inputs
21 times the number of inputs to the
other one so if they both have inputs
they both have an input bit of like n to
the log n so we did this with
conditional mutual information Scott and
Donna and ruslan pedazo independently
did it using epsilon net just like the
National equilibrium thing so it's kind
of cute that there seem to be these two
different things and giving like
identical run times and so one corollary
is we also get a sort of hardness result
for entangled games but a really wacky
and not particularly useful one it's one
where you have root end players but you
only sort of talked to two of them so
you choose Alice and then one of the
Bob's at random and only play with that
pair if you were to sort of fully write
that game down would be far too big but
you get something slightly not trivial
with this weird for the game where you
only talk to one of the players on
another application which Apollo's
estimate earlier is a deeper Nettie
theorem so everything up some Italians
have been four four four boxes but I
mentioned that you can reconstruct a
quantum state by looking at local
measures so how does that work here well
if Rho is a quantum state k extendable
and new with the distribution over
operations on Alice this is a slight
generalization instead of just talking
about measurements on Alice which is
like an operation with the classical
output we can do a quantum operation
which means that an operation with a
potentially quantum outlet so that's a
slight generalization what I said before
but the proof follows exactly the same
lines then we can approximate it and
what's the analog of localism variable
it's a separable state so there's a good
separable state approximating it with
respect to UM
with respect to some measurement for Bob
and this average over quantum operations
for Alice and again you only pay for the
output dimension of Alice so you
potentially useful for games because
even if alice is input is infinite
dimensional you're only paying for the
output of it and there's also a sort of
a multi-party version of this you know
we had theorem 142 party theorem 2 for
multi-party sort of analogous but let me
let me not go into details about it and
it's sort of compared to brando
crescendo yard it simplifies it improves
in a number of ways by making the
dependence on the output dimension
having a small type are tight version
simplifying the proof and giving an
explicit rounding algorithm to produce
statement instead of just showing that
one exists um so let me out so there
should be lying between these it
disappeared so let me kind of summarize
the places where we can use these
hierarchies and something that I kind of
just realized well I've suspected for a
while to kind of just realized yesterday
in a conversation with Fernando so we
have a number of algorithms where we can
approach them either using the
information theory techniques of
conditional mutual information that I've
been talking about or using epsilon net
so approximate Nash or optimizing a
quadratic function is one of them so
there's this you know I have this
approached that I just described to you
the original algorithm is lifting maître
in mark caucus from ten years ago they
use in epsilon net gives the same
performance for free games Fernando and
I have this thing that I just described
Scott Donna and Russell have this other
approach again same performance just
different methods maximizing over
separable states I just described a
theorem about about maximizing if you
have a measurement and you want to
maximize the probability that it accepts
given input separable state you can
think of this as a way of performing at
maximization and this started with
Randolph sandal yard and and sort of
there's been some number of people
looking at it you can also do with
epsilon net so yo Ian and Xiao de have a
paper on this and sort of preliminary
but sort of
today Fernando told me a way that I
think you can improve it to kind of
match this performance I think the
general story is whenever you can do the
information theory stuff experience you
can also do epsilon net I would love to
know sort of a more unifying principle
behind this and at this point I I can I
can point out the the fact that they
seem to track each other pretty closely
but I I can't sort of intelligently tell
you why geometry appears to be important
here I haven't managed to fit it into
the information theory yet okay so let
me briefly mention an open question um
so here's our theorem right k extendable
and your Vishnu then there's a local
invariable model that that's close to it
but you know can we switch the order the
quantifiers it's pretty unsatisfactory
how Q depends on you so here's a
conjecture there is if P is K extendable
then right away no more quantifiers very
this Q and it's good if it's good for
all new in particular it's good for the
singleton for the deterministic
distributions we just put in an input a
so we can simplify this a little further
and just say max over a B of this output
is is closed it's a nice simple
conjecture and don't get too attached to
it because if it were true then p would
equal NP so probably not true because
why if this were true then we could
approximate non signaling games not just
for product distributions but for
general distributions in we could do
that efficiently on but we know that
those are np-hard so probably can't do
it um but okay so fine what's not ruled
out um in the quantum case it still
could be true so it doesn't contradict
known hardness results for quantum games
in part because it's true player so it
could be that if row with K extendable
there's a separable stage that
approximates it well against all
measurements and we know already from
bcy that there's a separable state that
gives you a good approximation in the
one llcc norm so isn't this practice of
the same well I want that how I want the
performance depend on the number of
outcomes of Alice's measurement
so you're saying oh it would take to
kill this conjecture with me to improve
tomoz result from three player to do
player I think so right we will improve
two players well will be weaker than
Thomas result would be like for console
number of players okay we just might
simple way of combating oh oh yeah yeah
you're right actually sorry yeah yeah
yeah yeah no right so if this were true
right so what would it give it would
basically just keep something no
stronger than 20 miles results okay yeah
like what foreigners uh oh I say I say
okay actually and actually with four
players instead of three I said given
the parameters that we have uh yeah dude
uh yes is that not obviously false um
and um unlike everything I'm totally so
far it would have to do something you
have to not work for not singling
distributions so all the progress I've
been talking about has been progress you
can make by just looking at quantum
states as boxes you know just looking at
as them as as ways of generating joint
conditional probability distributions uh
and now this is an example without
approach is not enough because it's
somehow you have to you the proof
technique that fails for non signaling
dismission that works for quantum states
so I don't know much out there tomasz
proof is an example of that obviously so
but there's some ideas in there that
might work maybe a simpler idea is a
pretty good measurement I don't I think
it's a beautiful question and I don't
really gotta solve it let me skip some
other applications and get to open
questions so first one is switch
quantifiers we want a separable
approximation that a is independent of
the distribution on measurements and B
has air depending on the size of the
output and at the input we can achieve a
or b just that both together um and I
know and there's no obvious reason why
should be false even with conjecture
improvements to the tomasz result that's
a hard question here's an easier
question we know the non signaling value
version is false can you just write down
a counterexample distribution so just
write down an extendable non figlia
distribution that's far from local
hidden variable models now you could do
this by following through
the NP hardness result and then doing
the linear program but if you look at
those papers you know when you string
together all of these PPP's it gets kind
of long and hard for a human understand
um well maybe maybe if you're a PCP
expert you can do it actually but even
then it's not just the PCP it's like the
PCP and then the LP solution so I think
it would be I think if you try a direct
assault via the NP hardness it might be
22 incomprehensible there should be a
simple counterexample out there just
like the universal counter example of
quantum states is this anti symmetric
state that's been really really
productive think about it would be
really great to have some non signaling
example that was like that um this one I
could have skipped that part of the talk
if you nice to improved affinity
theorems there's sort of these other
improvements out there that exists like
exponential difa netting in the
post-election principle it'd be nice to
get sort of an allah combining those
improvements with the improvements i
described in the talks and finally we
have epsilon net achieve kind of similar
results it'd be nice to sort of
understand why we keep on getting
similar results for epsilon nets and
these information three approaches okay
thanks for your time
ask a question so so I really like the
site here some approximating in several
things with extendable is there any
concept which will do the same from
monsey cling to quantify put some more
thing that maybe we also want to go down
from on civilly to quantum it some nice
intermediate steps well I guess there's
the the NPA hierarchy right oh no you're
not different p sorry different uh yeah
for there's you know there's this
hierarchy of the noncommutative other
film stock and it'd be great to really
be able to analyze it a little bit
better yeah it's definitely it
definitely seems pretty promising and if
we don't have many other ideas so I
think that's throw to others have other
ideas yeah i think that like all of our
upper bounds to quantum that separate
quantum from not signaling i think they
all are basically just people writing
down dual points to the tire as far as i
can tell so but that doesn't mean we
understand it yeah
the German optimal result very signal
sort of lower bound by so the sizes of
games saf3 set that are sounding it's
not signaling creatures because
so in your monogamy nada get log at the
output or logically input log in the
input right so so what does that say
that unless we set some sub exponential
time that right I guess you would say
that that's right that these things are
just not sounding if not taken any
provers but that's I'm not sure you
don't email me today I just had that was
just from the linear programming the
characterization of I'm signaling oh
right but i think but i think if you
want to argue that non signaling games
need I don't basically I think you can
argue that non signaling games are not
sound if you try and do it like non
signaling game 4-3 that you want to
argue that snap sound I don't think you
need our results I don't think it
matters there they're free or whatever
because I think that's just a LP
characterization says not sending games
are easy so unless you can solve three
tenets of exponential time then they're
not if you try and do a non signaling
game 4-3 sad it's gonna have that sounds
or subjects financially so i think that
i think the easiness of non singling
games is what gives you is what that is
is what will give you that type of
result what are monogamy does is it
tells you the hardness of not signaling
things because it says if you take an
extendable if you take a symmetric not
signaling game then the marginal does it
look like local game variable and so
that says that if you you know that
gives you sort of converse I guess to it
ok so what are if you were done more
journal type of extension for example we
could rephrase equal by dominating and
order for the second ball being the
square of the first bomb I that's very
question I don't know it's possible that
in some of these hierarchies you might
sort of get that for free but I'm not
know I don't know that's a very good
question to think about ok looks like
here we go